[Musique]
bonjour eric ciotti bonjour on l'a
effectivement entendu à 7h30 le premier
ministre réunit ses troupes ce matin
pour mettre en musique les annonces des
manuels macron la semaine dernière qu
est ce que vous espérez de ce moment la
rapidité de la célérité de l'action mais
en réalité tout ça n'est que de la
communication
demain ça fera deux ans que le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 a eu lieu deux ans quasiment qui
emmanuel macron un président de la
république
quelle est la situation du pays la
violence dans la rue avec la crise qu'on
connaît depuis cinq mois maintenant une
situation modérément
on a des inquiétudes pour le 1er mai on
a une situation économique est très
dégradée est ce que la france va bien
non est ce que la france va mieux non
est-ce qu'elle va mieux que nos
partenaires européens ou internationaux
non le président les paramètres sont
dégradées aujourd'hui leone est le plus
mauvais élève de l'europe en matière
d'impôts on est le plus mauvais élèves
en matière de déficit
et au bout de deux ans finalement c'est
quoi le maquereau nisme plus d'impôts et
plus d'immigration elle est là donc il
serait peut-être temps d'arrêter de
parler je crois que le président public
à part les 40 heures pendant grand débat
et il fallait ses 40 heures il fallait
tout ces réunions il fallait toute cette
agitation cette communication pour
arriver à la conclusion qu'on a trop
d'élections mais comprend finalement
aucune mesure courageuse pour les
baisser eric ciotti il ya un acte 2 qui
se prépare c'est ce qui explique on nous
dit c'est ce qui explique le père j ai
des mesures que vous venez d'évoquer
notamment sur les baisses d'impôt
comment sur la question des baisses
d'impôts alors que le gouvernement
propose à peu de choses près ce que
proposaient les républicains vous pouvez
ne pas demander justement la rapidité
d'action adéquat des précisions il ya un
très gros écart avec ce que nous
proposons nous ce que nous demandons
avec laurent wauquiez c'est une baisse
de 10% pour tout le monde tout de suite
de l'impôt sur le revenu nous demandons
l'annulation de la taxe sur l'essence
aussi mises en places en 2018 par
monsieur macro l'essence va atteindre un
niveau plus
v qu'à l'automne dernier aucune
disposition sur cet enjeu essentiel des
déplacements pour beaucoup de ménages et
de ménage boisé la question des baisses
d'impôts je regrette juste des
précisions vous demandez nous nous
demandons d'aller beaucoup plus loin
mais pour aller plus loin il faut un
préalable caroline roux il faut du
courage le courage de baisser les
dépenses publiques parce que si on ne
baisse pas les dépenses vie qu on a le
record je parlais de records tout à
l'heure on a le record d'europe des
dépenses publiques si on n'a pas cet
effort pour faire des économies sur le
train de vie de l'état pour diminuer la
bureaucratie et bien on n'arrivera pas à
diminuer les impôts on va s'endetter
on va s'endetter à crédit on va creuser
les déficits et ce seront les impôts de
demain donc c'est un marc gillet
aircraft est prêt je leur ai public dit
il faudra mettre des services publics au
plus près des français
bien sûr il forme un des services
publics je pense à la nécessité de mieux
nous protéger et les policiers
aujourd'hui traverse une crise majeure
et il faut leur donner des moyens mais
on a cinq millions et demi de
fonctionnaires c'est un million de plus
qu'un d'allemagne on a des coudes
bureaucratie énorme avec rien à perdre
et le fonctionnement des systèmes
sociaux des régimes pour prélever
notamment les les cotisations coûte plus
que le budget de l'intérieur en france
c'est ça c'est trop regretter qu'il est
abandonné l'objectif de la réduction de
100 années le pas sur mais bien sur cet
objectif
nicolas sarkozy l'avait obtenu et il
avait fait des économies
hollande naturellement a fait augmenter
le nombre de fonctionnaires et macro
continue c'est finalement la dégradation
c'est un peu le holland empire on l'a
dénoncé à l'assemblée nationale avec
christian jacob et mais ça se poursuive
et j'aimerais comprendre c'est quelles
sont les priorités à vos yeux on a bien
vu qu'il ya beaucoup de chantiers qui
sont ouverts par le président de la
république dans ce qu'il souhaite être
un acte 2 de son quinquennat
à votre avis quelles sont les priorités
dans ce qui a été énoncé puisque là le
sujet c'est de mettre en place un agenda
les priorités pour nous très clairement
c'est la baisse de la fiscalité le
record des prélèvements obligatoires est
insupportable avec une
si bien sûr qu'en parallèle des dépenses
publiques et il faut penser à ceux qui
souffrent le plus à ceux qui ont été les
victimes de ce pouvoir je pense
notamment aux retraités
deux retraités sur trois ont vu leur
pouvoir d'achat baisser depuis deux ans
des exceptions oui mais l'indexation
c'est dans un an et donc en 2019 les
retraites les pensions de retraite vont
continuer de baisser
je pense aux automobilistes je pense à
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui travaillent et
ne bénéficient pas du fruit de leur
travail pour le faire une priorité un
mot sur la réforme constitutionnelle
parmi les annonces il ya un sujet sur
lequel le président lequel présent on va
avoir besoin de vous c'est bien la
révision constitutionnelle pour être
adoptée je le rappelle le texte doit
être voté par trois cinquièmes du
parlement soit 555 élu il aura donc
besoin de la droite sénatoriale quelle
sera l'attitude de la droite d'une
manière générale sur cette révision
constitutionnelle avec les corrections
quand même qu'ils ont été apportées par
le président de la république notamment
sur la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires il a dit si c'est pas 30%
cissé 25 est ce que ça peut passer
nous on ne veut pas de bricolage
institutionnel la vème république la
stabilité de la vème république voulu
par le général de gaulle
c'est finalement le plus grand atout de
de la france aujourd'hui ça nous protège
et ça protège même aujourd'hui dans des
moments de crise ce pouvoir qui est
tellement fragile donc il ne faut pas
toucher à l'édifice institutionnel
regardons ce qui se passe en espagne
demain avec le jeu de la proportionnelle
regardons ce qui se passe dans d'autres
pays on va aller vers l'instabilité
politique
l'obligation vous venez avec les haies
en réalisant des socialistes en tout cas
la conjugaison de la proportionnelle et
de la baisse du nombre de parlementaires
ça a fait dire à l'arrêt la
représentation des territoires là où on
veut plus de proximité et surtout on va
aller avec le poison de la
proportionnelle vers le régime des
partis le retour à la ivème république
le fait qu'on ne sache pas au moment
d'une élection comme ça c'est le cas en
espagne où comme ça a été le cas en
allemagne
qui va gouverner sans le refuse
après-demain organisations syndicales
formations politiques mais aussi gilet
jaune vont se retrouver avec certains
appellent même à l'émeute à paris qu'on
voit fleurir désormais sur les réseaux
sociaux pour la fête du travail pour le
1er mai qu'attendez-vous comme garantie
en matière de maintien de l'ordre dans
la mesure où on annonce déjà une journée
compliquée c'est naturellement
préoccupant est inquiétant moi je fais
confiance aux forces de police de
gendarmerie à l'intérieur beaucoup moins
au ministre de l'intérieur pasqua depuis
cinq mois il n'a pas pris les bonnes
décisions et il n'a pas donné aux forces
de l'ordre les moyens de leur action je
regrette notamment je le dis que le
gouvernement n'ait pas tenu compte de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel sur
la loi anti casseurs qui avaient été
proposées par les républicains et qu'on
n'ait pas repris ce texte à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire en sorte que les
groupuscules violents comprenez qu'ils
seront là le 1er mai et notamment les
black blocks d'extrême gauche soit
interdit de manifester
c'est un manque de courage mais ce
manque de courage finalement c'est un
peu le trait de ce pouvoir sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration sur la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical portant sur
des sujets qui ont été évoqués par ils
ont été évoqués mais depuis deux ans ça
fait deux ans qu'ils sont là
on attend des actes et pas des paroles
les français en ont soupé des paroles
ils veulent de l'action même
merci beaucoup et verts s'étaient
retirés